Speaker 1: All right, I'm going to show you
here a video that is like the perfect storm
of the most perverted anti vax insanity, combined
with the continued absurdity and hypocrisy
of Fox hosts who work for a company that has
a stricter vaccine policy than what Joe Biden
outlined a couple of weeks ago, continuing
to gin up their audiences by giving airtime
to the wackiest, most unhinged anti vaccine and
anti science voices. Who am I talking about? I'm
talking about comedian Jim Breuer and Fox News
host Tucker Carlson. This you have to see this
to believe it. As Huffington Post writes this, I
love this headline. Saturday Night Lives Goat Boy.
Meaning? Meaning Jim Brewer rants about the beast,
barks like a seal in a while, the anti vax rant.
Now, there's two elements to this. First,
it's the nonsense that Jim Brewer says.
Second, it's Tucker nodding along and saying right
and praising Jim Brewer for saying this stuff.
And then in addition to that, the Fox audience
who thinks, wow, Tucker is really standing up for
what he believes is right. Fox News not only
requires vaccination or testing, otherwise,
if you're not vaccinated, you've got to test
every day at FOX. Remember, Biden said every
week you get a test every day at Fox and you got
to wear masks as well. That's stricter than so.
Tucker works there, but on air, he does the
anthrax apologia. So let's get right into it.
This is crazy. Brewer seems out of his mind, but
Speaker 2: the principle remains, if you
can force people to get the vaccine,
Speaker 1: what can't you do? Right.
Speaker 2: That's a question that Jim Brewer
appears to be thinking about. He's a comedian.
He's announced he's not performing at any
venue that requires patrons to be vaccinated.
Speaker 1: So that's the gist
of this, that Jim Brewer said,
I'm canceling shows where
the venue says everybody's
got to be vaccinated and now he's a hero.
Speaker 2: Joins us tonight to explain why.
Jim Moret, thanks so much for coming on.
Interesting that you did this. It caught
our attention. Why tell us I'll be quiet
as you explain why you did this. Yeah.
Well, honestly, I got a lot of feedback from a
couple of venues that I was playing and my fans
were really upset. They said, you know, I'm not
comfortable with getting a covid shot. And and
now they're saying, I can't come see you perform
unless I do that. And I looked into it. And that's
the last thing you should be doing, is going,
hey, you want to come, you want to come see the
you like feeding the seal, the fish. Hey, you want
to you want to come see a concert or you want to.
Speaker 1: That's funny guys. He's barking
like a seal. This is a it's a it's the
point is better because he's barking.
Speaker 2: Well here comes the fit. Why
would you do that. Why would you. I don't
want any of my fans forced to come laugh
and they've got to get a shot in them.
Speaker 1: OK, so as much as as much as
Jim Brewer might love it for people to be forced
to go to his show, no one's being forced to do
anything. It's comedy is optional. OK, if they
don't want to get a shot, then they don't have to
go to the show. They can go to a different show or
they can look at his clips online or they can do.
Nobody's being forced to go to comedy shows
at all. As much as Jim Brewer might love it
if it was mandatory to go to his comedy. It's not.
Speaker 2: And and honestly, Tucker, I got to be
honest with you, what really what really started
my video was there's a new narrative and the new
narrative is the unvaccinated are the beast,
kill the Beast. This, this, this program.
Speaker 1: And notice, Tucker says, exactly.
That's an idea Tucker has been pushing. He did
it with some candidate on his daytime show. Like
I said, I think I think the left wants to kill the
unvaccinated. And Tucker's like, absolutely
Speaker 2: goes on forever. Kill the beast,
the beast to see unvaccinated kill
them. And when when our leader
Speaker 1: you can tell
his comedy is really funny.
Speaker 2: Put that out there and
pointed the finger like where the demons.
I'm not vaccinated. I had covid. You're not
going to tell me about my body. I know. I know
my body. I know my morals. I know my faith.
You don't come telling me and threaten me and
everyone else as if we're the demons I have.
Speaker 1: So at this point, we're not even on
planet Earth. You know, you don't come to threaten
me as if I'm the demon. What he's talking about is
Biden said if you have over one hundred employees,
they should be vaccinated or test weekly.
And then venues are legally able to require
vaccines if they want to. Jim Brewer, is that
demons and faith and all these different things to
Speaker 2: close friends right now fully
vaccinated and they got covid. Yeah, and they're
both sick. So what is this is not about safety,
because if it was you just like you said
and I said in my video to eat more fruit,
take care of your body. Now, remember,
Speaker 1: there is no evidence that
eating fruit prevents covid the I guess they're
alluding to if you're generally healthier overall,
your risk of death is lower from all
causes. But that's not specific to covid
Speaker 2: go the gym. I've been saying it
forever. You would have thought I called people
savages for doing that. But this is where society
and the greatest thing I have to be honest with
you. Please, I'm so blessed because 95 percent
of people I was just saying it, to be honest,
Tucker, one message after the other was, thank
you. Thank you for speaking up. Thank you. I
feel terrible. I'm a fireman and they want me to
get vaccinated. I don't want to get vaccinated.
My my child. I know someone at my hand to God.
Speaker 1: So is it obviously a lie?
Because he said hand to God, I don't know.
Speaker 2: And it was the last vaccine push their
child, five years old, vaccinated when paralyzed.
Speaker 1: OK, who's vaccinating five year olds?
Am I missing something? Has the vaccine
been approved for five years? How is
who is this five year old that got
a vaccine? Were they part of a trial
Speaker 2: from the neck down? And I do a
benefit or a benefit for them every year.
Speaker 1: Oh, I guess this. Oh, oh, this
is more so. He thinks some other vaccine
paralyzed a kid. Is that the claim now?
Speaker 2: So when I hear people going,
oh, no, no, no, you don't. OK, so
Speaker 1: a bizarre rant, barking like a
seal in opposition to vaccination. There is Jim
Brewer. And that's pretty scary because he's an
entertainer and all sorts of people just see what
he says and they love it. They love it and they
just accept it. So that was going on. And Tucker
Carlson, absolutely loving it and praising it.